Okay, so disgusting, depraved, diabolical
disgrace of a senator Ted Cruz was confronted
at lax airport with a chance of free the children.
We have it on video and I'm here to tell you
again, this is okay. I'm okay with this and
I know people are going to write to me and
tell me no, David. No, it's immoral for you
to be okay with this. I'm okay with it. And
I'll tell you why in a second. Let's look
at the video first. Ted Cruz, the recipient
of all sorts of chance and booing Cruz. Meanwhile,
taking pictures with fans in the midst of
the chat. It's pretty funny. Video
[inaudible] this
has happened to Cruz before. Uh, we covered
the incident last year where he was heckled
out of a restaurant in Washington, D C so
listen, I'm okay with this. I'm against physical
violence. I am against throwing anything at
politicians or whoever, including milkshakes.
That's a crime you can get arrested for it.
I'm against property crimes against the homes
of elected officials that we don't like. This
is just speech. Is it loud? It's sort of loud.
It's group speech. It's more than one person.
That's true. These are politicians who are
doing disgusting things. They're complicit
or even supportive of policies that are ruining
people's lives irrevocably. Yes, it's uncomfortable
to be at an airport and to have a crowd chanting
stuff at you. I can understand that. If it
can happen at Ted Cruz, it could happen to
Bernie or Warren or me or whoever, and it
has happened to Bernie as we've covered before.
In fact, there was Alex Jones who was heckling
Bernie in that viral video that we covered,
but there is not nearly enough being done
to make our elected officials actually feel
uncomfortable for the policies that they're
supporting and carrying out. It's very easy
for our elected officials to be completely
isolated between their security and their
sedan services, uh, and their first class
lounges and whatever else. It's very easy
to be completely isolated from the reactions
of people beyond what they read on Twitter.
This is called your actions have consequences.
It feels so weak. When people write to me
and say, David, it's not okay to heckle politicians
in a public place. It's not respectful. They're
advocating for policies that would lead to
tens of millions losing access to health care.
They're supporting the interrogation and the
moral caging of children, or at least looking
the other way about it.
They're debating whether or not children in
cages deserve soap and a toothbrush when they're
held for days on end. They're defending one
of the most immoral, corrupt presidents that
we have had. And you're saying it's inappropriate
to chant in a public space. We need to draw
the line in a reasonable place. The line is,
before we get to property crime, the line
is before we get to setting fire to things,
but wine is before street beatings or whatever
else, right? Chanting in public. Come on guys.
This is not sensible. This is not logical.
I'm open to having my mind changed, but you've
got to make a good argument as to why I should
be against it.
Chanting at Ted Cruz in public. Quick break.
Give us a like on Facebook, facebook.com/david
Pakman show. We'll be right back after this